you are the Black Panther you need
control speed and power
hello it's some swag very nice
let's go
[Music]
the binges are suiting up for their next
mission but until the summer arrived as
a whole new Marvel movie headed your way
don't miss Marvel Studios Black Panther
coming soon to a theater near you and if
it's not near you then get in a car or
playing bus-train white scape art run
and get your butt to the movie yeah man
[Music]
[Laughter]
hi I'm Robert Downey jr. this is such an
exciting moment I'm here with Chadwick
Boseman who plays Black Panther I got
questions yeah all right
for anybody who didn't see Civil War can
you reiterate the events leading up to
now and his place among the Avengers
well the Avengers leave that movie sort
of split between the Iron Man side and
cap side so he took your side what Conda
being this almost mystic locale can you
tell us what is so special about his
home country
we are whole part of it is that it's a
mystery it has a lot of Natural
Resources one of those Bay vibranium but
much more you hiding which you have a
lot of yeah yeah I got a little what's
the vibranium for damage report mr.
Francis I've never played a king before
so I'm just wondering how do you prepare
for that you want people like yourself I
was hoping you'd say that
you decide what kind of to you are what
I've seen and I'll just say it right
here you're the right man for the job
man I cannot wait to see this
you are a good king and you are
deserving of this crown Thank You Man
thank you Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody so we got some new black
panther to talk about its dropping this
week but because Avengers is coming
right after it they're doing full-blown
crossover so some of you may have
forgotten that he was actually team Iron
Man during civil war although the funny
thing about that is that teaming up with
Iron Man was nowhere on his to-do list
he just wanted Winter Soldier in Ironman
had already assembled his team to take
him in Captain America had his team so
it was really just born out of
convenience I'm sure he knows all about
Tony Stark he probably has a certain
level of respect for him as a
technologist but I don't think he trusts
him that much especially because of his
history as a weapons dealer in a way
before that Howard Stark had some
experience with vibranium so Black
Panthers family probably was aware of
what was going on in the United States
with a super soldier program especially
with Red Skull the Red Room everything
that was going on in the world in the
MCU going back to that first Captain
America movie because currently that's
the earliest we've been to in the
timeline if you don't count the
prehistory from the Thor movies because
you get that big back story with hellas
characters that goes way back thousands
of years before any of the Avengers were
ever born so no spoilers for Black
Panther no worries we'll do those videos
later this week after everybody has a
chance to see the movie but the movie
itself does do a good job of placing it
in the history of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like what was happening when
all this other stuff was going on during
the events of Captain America so while
the movie is very specific to the
history of the black panther character
you can't tell that without telling the
history of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in certain ways so if you've been
watching all the Marvel movies just keep
your ears and your eyes peeled for
Easter eggs like that when they talk
about things and think about the
timeline remember Captain America back
during World War 2 era the rest of the
timeline really picks up with the death
of Tony Stark's parents at the hands of
Winter Soldier and then all the stuff up
through the Cold War in ant-man the
early 90s obviously Captain Marvel takes
place during the 90s so really from
about 1940 then you take a couple jumps
and then that's really where most of the
storytelling happens but this promo is
actually a good taste of what the promos
for infinity war are gonna be like they
did the same thing for Civil War where
they tried to do the Deadpool thing of
doing promos that weren't really promos
like stuff without giving away a whole
bunch of footage except every man
woman and child in this country and
around the world to live free free from
tyranny and free from oppression so I'm
just really excited to see what they try
and do
here's that black panther clip that they
released where he talks about Easter
eggs specific to his character in the
phase one and Phase two movies before we
ever knew that there was gonna be a
black panther movie my character comes
from a place called Wakanda while that
name may not be familiar it's actually
connected to the Avengers universe in
ways you never knew in fact it might be
the most talked about out of any other
Marvel movie you know believe me let's
travel back all the way to 2010 with
Iron Man 2
at the end of Iron Man 2 we seek Nick
Fury and Tony Stark talking I take a
closer look at the map behind them
there's a few locations highlighted
including Wakanda where I'm from
we'll be going and Captain America the
First Avenger we discover his shield is
made of vibranium that's the rarest
metal on earth what's important about
vibranium
it's made in only one place now the
first time we're contes mentioned
happens to be an Avengers age of Ultron
thanks to my boy Bruce Walken nada what
whoa whoa whoa whoa Conda
really okay he may not have said it
right but he's still sitting and finally
become the Captain America Civil War or
you meet me for the first time
goodness and where is Bucky being
relocated to you know if they find out
he's here comes me what kinda
so you see it may have been oh I don't
know three five seven years later let me
know in the comments how many of you
spotted those Easter eggs when those
movies first came out I don't think I
was making youtube videos when Iron Man
2 came out but I definitely remember
making videos for Iron Man 3 but I think
most people saw those like especially
this map during to the end of Iron Man 2
we're like wait a minute
that's Africa that's where Wakanda is is
this a black panther Easter Egg because
Nick Fury is talking about Avengers Tony
Stark's arguing about how he's not good
enough imagine what this kind of video
is gonna look like in another 10 years
it's gonna be crazy so just a bit of
housekeeping black panther Easter eggs
post-credit scenes all those more
spoilery videos like my spoiler review
that we'll post at the end of this week
just to give people a chance to see the
movie but do make sure to go see it this
weekend so you have a chance to talk
about it with everybody because there's
nothing worse than having something
really cool come out and not being able
to talk about it because you haven't
seen it yet there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video I'll name a
winner when I post a new Marvel video I
have a new Thor video that I'll post
tomorrow so click here for brand new
Avengers and click here for that brand
new Deadpool video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]